bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau 7,8 le
débat c'est parti pour l'édition 2010
est du baccalauréat les épreuves
démarrent ce jeudi si le bac reste
perçue par les français comme un examen
important il perd en crédibilité pour
plus de sept français sur dix le fameux
diplôme soutien plus facilement
aujourd'hui qu'il y a vingt ans avec le
regain de popularité des formations
professionnelles et l'arrivée de
nouveaux modèles d'enseignement obtenir
le bac ne semble plus être un impératif
pour trouver son chemin vers le monde
professionnel avec nous pour en débattre
ce soir rené macron directeur adjoint de
l'académie de versailles et alain parce
qu'aux développeurs de l'apprentissage
au tfm btp de trappes bonsoir messieurs
bonsoir rené mack ronde le bac reste
quand même indispensable
voilà pour mettre le plus de chances de
son côté
alors le bac reste utile très utile déjà
c'est la porte d'entrée de l'université
pour ceux qui souhaitent y arriver il
est dispensé à près de 90% de la
population aujourd'hui donc les
candidats sont nombreux et les reçus le
sont aussi avec ou sans mention
donc on est quand même aujourd'hui dans
une situation où on a un grand nombre
d'élèves qui passent le baccalauréat et
qu'il réussisse et qui cherche à
poursuivre des études après alors toute
la question est de savoir quel type
d'étude ils vont poursuivre et dans
quelles conditions
et là effectivement on s'aperçoit que on
a aujourd'hui une représentation du
baccalauréat comme étant la porte
d'entrée de l'université exclusivement
et comme étant la voie royale
lorsqu'on a passé un baccalauréat
général may à venir et d'autres grandes
écoles
la classe préparatoire et tout et puis
il ya des élèves qui vont faire leur
suite pour cette étude dans des
formations de
les techniciens supérieurs dans des iut
ds les bts les unités qui sont des voies
de grande réussite aussi
donc on a des multiplicité aujourd'hui
baccalauréat depuis le baccalauréat
général jusqu'au baccalauréat
professionnel et tous ces bacs offre des
possibilités de poursuite d'études et ce
qui nous semble aujourd'hui important
c'est précisément que l'on ne l'y
hiérarchise pas trop les différents bacs
et que l'on puisse constater que c'est
la sanction d'un cycle d'études
c'est l'entrée vers une poursuite
d'études
mais quel que soit le baccalauréat on a
toujours une poursuite d'études
possibles
j'ajouterai que son parent site d'études
allez-y peu cette poursuite d'études
elle peut se faire en milieu scolaire
elle peut sert aussi un apprentissage
geste plusieurs sortes de d'études
possibles laissant intervenir à
l'impasse co l'apprentissage c'est un
peu le maître mot de toutes les
politiques de lutte contre le chômage
ces dernières années c'est vraiment une
voie d'accès plus directe à l'emploi ah
oui complètement parce que donc je
confirme ce que macron viens de dire
nous nous sommes en recherche
nous manquons vraiment vraiment de
jeunes pour venir vers nous filière du
bâtiment et des travaux publics et c'est
ça fait partie des candidates difficile
à trouver des jeunes difficiles à
recruter parce que nos entreprises nous
demandent viennent vers nous pour
chercher des jeunes qui feront une
formation en alternance dans leur
entreprise pour cette formation bac
professionnel travaux publics ou
bâtiment et on commence forcément bac
vraiment on peut commencer bien avant
dessus à doha fait et puis on peut
continuer ensuite évidemment nous
effectuons aussi aussi chine des bts et
puis après on peut ensuite continué ses
études c'est vraiment une des voies
possibles pour
continue ses études une manière générale
et a accédé en fait c'était un emploi
rapidement plus rapidement grâce à
l'alternance notamment absolument tout à
fait prêt des macros il ya quand même on
entend beaucoup de parents dire
maintenant donne le bac à tout le monde
que dites vous eh bien on donne le bac
est à peu près 90% des candidats ce qui
vient on à et vous me disiez en charge
en cette émission qu'à votre époque
lorsque j'ai passé moi même le bac non
ce n'était pas exactement le cas on en
était très très loin donc évidemment il
ya une impression que de dévalorisation
qui est essentiellement liée au nombre
de candidats est au nombre de reçus
c'est pas bon angle et c'est pas parce
que ils sont nombreux à être reçus
qu'ils ne sont pas bons à nos élèves
ils sont nombreux à être reçue plutôt
parce qu'ils sont beaux et qu'ils ont
ils ont travaillé correctement donc je
pense que cette cette vision était
faussée par la représentation que l'on a
de ce qu'est un baccalauréat dans une
tradition dans laquelle quelques-uns de
l'élite avaient le baccalauréat
aujourd'hui il est vrai que la poursuite
d'études se fait pour de très nombreux
élèves tous les élèves vont au collège
à l'époque où j'ai passé le bac elle
reviendra tous les élèves au collège à
peu près tous les élèves entrent au
lycée ou très peu
ne le font pas c'est son ami mais je
pense que c'est une très très belle
et j'ajoute que les élèves qui échoue au
baccalauréat leur passent parfois leur
passe d'ailleurs ce statut d'apprenti il
enfin papa pour le bac mais on est en
alternance et y réussissent donc c'est
une bonne nouvelle qu'un grand nombre
d'élèves réussissent le baccalauréat et
c'est une bonne nouvelle que un grand
nombre de nos bacheliers souhaitent
poursuivre leurs études et je salue
vraiment le travail qui est fait par les
cfa travail que nous faisons nous-mêmes
l'éducation ne s'en excusent d'apprentis
nous avons voilà sort de formation des
apprentis
nous avons nous mêmes des centres de
formation d'apprentis dans l'académie de
versailles on a on est en train
d'ailleurs de construire un grand centre
de formation académique qui aurait une
force de frappe plus importante et c'est
une voie de réussite tout à fait
importante à la fois parce que ça
correspond à au souhait de certains
jeunes
ça correspond parfois à leurs besoins
certains noms des jeunes ne peuvent pas
financer les études au delà du
baccalauréat et puis ça correspond aux
besoins des entreprises qui cherchent
effectivement vous l'avez dit très
justement tu cherches aujourd'hui des du
personnel qualifié alain parce que quand
même on se rend compte que dans la
réalité ces filières professionnelles
pâtissent un petit peu d'une mauvaise
image à on sent que on n'y est pas
encore dans une
vraie valorisation de ces filières oui à
quoi ben oui alors peut-être c'est vrai
que les jeunes ne viennent pas forcément
facilement à nous pour ces métiers là je
pense qu'aujourd'hui peut être qu'on
souffre d'un déficit de communication
aussi naturellement on entend beaucoup
parler de l'internet des métiers
l'électronique de l'informatique toutes
les applications sur les smartphones
encourage les jeunes à penser qu'ils
pourront aller vers ces métiers
et puis on s'en doute beaucoup moins des
métiers du bâtiment et des travaux
publics
donc moi j'encourage tous les leviers
plus manuels voilà plus manuels plus qui
permettent de voir concrètement ce qu on
a fait quand on a travaillé une chaude
journée sur un chantier qu'on a
construit un pont une autoroute à
bâtiment à la fin de juin
on a vu l'on a vu ce que ce qu'on a fait
donc j'encourage vraiment les chefs
d'établissement à questionner les jeunes
leur dire leur demander si voilà ces
métiers enfin en tout cas leur faire
prendre connaissance que ces métiers
sont à leur portée s'ils ont envie d'y
aller évidemment nous serons heureux d
accueillir les accompagner tout au long
de cette formation d'apprentissage qui
est un petit peu spécifique parce qu'on
rentre plus rapidement dans le monde
dans l'ombre du travail oit et à quel
niveau ça peut se jouer est ce que c'est
c'est un problème d'aiguillage avec les
conseillers d'orientation à à quel
moment on peut être sûr de bien aiguillé
les lèvres
il faut commencer tôt c'est-à-dire au
collège
donc commencer dès la classe de 4e 4 et
la place de 4e on commence à travailler
avec les jeunes sur les entreprises les
métiers on a de nombreuses actions en
partenariat avec des entreprises sur le
secteur de lui en cours notamment
puisqu'on a de très très nombreuses
entreprises est d être nous et c'est
avec laquelle on travaille pour
permettre à des jeunes de mieux
connaître le monde de l'entreprise
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur
sur le déficit de communication me
semble un des éléments importants
aujourd'hui dans les filières
professionnelles notamment dans les
filières industrielles la la population
ne se représente pas nécessairement ce
que sans ces métiers aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que passé un
baccalauréat de chaudronnerie par
exemple ça n'a rien à voir avec la
fabrication des chaudrons serez vous
c'est un métier extrêmement technique
disais tout à l'heure allez visiter des
lycées professionnels du bois des
travaux publics et on verra que on a
affaire à des jeunes qui ont un métier
qu'ils étaient certains métiers manuels
dans la mesure où il voit comme vous le
disiez très justement ils voient se
construire l'objet sur lequel le travail
mais c'est aussi un métier extrêmement
technique avec des pilotages de machines
très très complexe et qui nécessite une
vraie formation et vous avez des gens
les portes ouvertes est pas complètement
oui bien sûr de sûr on peut rien faire
de plus bonne question bonnes questions
il faut au fond de nous on s'est en tous
les jours on est tous les jours on est
là pour informer les gens qui nous
appellent au téléphone
les gens qui s'inscrivent aussi chez
nous directement et qui effectivement
des fois un mélange même le bâtiment et
travaux publics parce que c'est depuis
hier un peu différente de la
construction donc on informe ont fait la
communication
on essaie de manière plus large de
participer à tous les forums moi même le
début de l'année janvier février mars on
va dans les municipalités à des journées
organisées par la ville pour présenter
l'alternance du maire général donc tous
les cfa sont présentés dans mon métier
dans les autres pour informer les
parents les jeunes finalement voilà que
ses métiers sur les métiers porteurs qui
permettent de d'avoir un vrai avenir et
de se développer aussi personnellement
parce que voilà c'est encore une fois si
je crois que quand on a dans ces métiers
là c'est très concret voilà c'est un
métier où on peut encore bien gagner sa
vie également tout à fait est-ce que
vous avez des chiffres nous donner sur
peut-être un salaire d'entrée ou un
salaire après quelques années une ba
pouy dans votre domaine dans le mélange
sur un cap et on peut commencer
rapidement après sa formation va être
tombé dans les allées ont été remis 500
euros alors après ça les points qui fait
de la taille des entreprises des
avantages qu'ils peuvent venir se
greffer sur le salaire de base mais
après rapidement dans des sorties en bac
pro on peut flirter que les 2000 euros
assez rapidement oui oui tout à fait oui
et ans et en plus on peut après le bac
pro aller vers une licence 1 sur leurs
bd à songe à lancer ensuite continué par
licence ou des complètement rené macron
de une conclusion chacun qu'est-ce que
penser de l'enseignement du futur il y a
effectivement ces filières
d'apprentissage mais on voit aussi
émerger des nouveaux centres
d'enseignement qui demande pas forcément
le bac etc
je pense à l'école de deuxième ligne
aile etc qu'est ce que vous en pensez du
bien du bien pour une raison très simple
c'est que une grande part de la réussite
des élèves
tiens la motivation qui est la leur et
donc si il faut trouver les moyens de ne
pas sélectionner les élèves uniquement
sur leurs résultats scolaires
alors ça nous savons très bien le faire
hein on n'a pas de problème on sait
mesurer mais il n'y a pas que ça dans la
vie et dans l'est dans les parcours et
il ya beaucoup de l'appétence du goût de
l'envy affaires et soul pense que
effectivement une communication sur les
types de métiers que l'on peut atteindre
à travers des formations et les
possibilités de passerelles qui sont
offertes aux élèves me semble tout à
fait importante nous nous constatons
aujourd'hui par exemple dans les lycées
généraux des élèves qui souhaitent se
réorienter vers le bac professionnel
alors même que quand il était au collège
il ne souhaitait pas y aller entre temps
ils ont mûri et ils ont trouvé une voie
de réussite pour eux on trouve
aujourd'hui des parents venant inscrire
des enfants
dans les lycées professionnels en
interrogeant les proviseurs pour savoir
s'il y a un bts disponible derrière donc
on voit qu'il ya quelque chose qui bouge
dans ce domaine là et que à partir du
moment où on sera dans une configuration
où on parvient à communiquer d'une part
et d'autre part on a des configurations
économiques qui permettent aux
entreprises de recruter mais en jouant
sur la palette à la fois de la formation
classique de l'information sous statut
d'apprenti y ait des nouvelles
formations qui se développe aujourd'hui
on a une chance de réussir à hausser le
niveau global de la population
alain presqu'au sur l'évolution de ces
mentalités oui oui je suis d'accord et
nous sommes accros on sent que les
parents fictivement maintenant ont pris
connaissance qu'il y avait une évolution
possible et que vers ces métiers
notamment pour les nôtres dans le
bâtiment et travaux publics
il y avait une vraie évolution on
utilise beaucoup l'informatique aussi
dans nos métiers on en utilise dès
maintenant des systèmes comme le bim qui
est qui est un concept de modélisation
3d 2d chantier donc chaque heure chaque
corps de métier vient porter sur une
modélisation ce qui va faire comment
comment est fabriqué construit le
bâtiment et pour les former le bim pas
précisément le bim
actuellement c'est en train de nous
allons faire sûrement très prochainement
mais pas au jour d'aujourd'hui mais
c'est en tout cas des défendu qu'on peut
trouver dans les cfa et puis surtout
aussi nous on les
les on leur dit que ces métiers ont
beaucoup évolué et s'est beaucoup
mécanisée il ya beaucoup moins autrefois
c'est vrai que c'était très physique les
métiers du bâtiment les tropiques
aujourd'hui c'est quand même une grosse
assistance
informatique également et puis et puis
et puis les concepts nouveaux comme les
routes intelligentes des décors des
concepts un petit peu aujourd'hui
moderne
voilà des choses qui n'existaient pas il
ya encore une dizaine d'années on essaie
évolue effectivement dans la pratique
dans leurs usages mais en retraite
beaucoup les déchets aujourd'hui une
autre fois on cassait on savait pas trop
où ça mais aujourd'hui on devrait avoir
un traitement des déchets le recyclage
et sera donc lui aussi une partie
écologique maintenant qu'on n'avait pas
autrefois les matières se fictivement se
mélanger à hybridation des genres et ça
rend la chose aussi le plus de traction
à l'étrier d'accord merci à tous les
deux participé à cette émission
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau débat merci très bonne soirée
[Musique]